Donald Trump gave a 45-minute speech
yesterday announcing he's running for
president 45-minute speech today news
outlets fact-checked the speech he gave
they found that it was riddled with
factual errors and inaccuracies now
Trump has already responded to the
criticism by reira leasing the speech
with all of the factual errors removed
let's take a look at that
mr. Trump you're not a nice person I'm
really rich thank you very much
[Applause]
Andy I'd much think I'm going to run for
president but when the time comes that I
do run for president will you remind me
to enter on an escalator yes yeah
reverse the exit on the way I just
there's something about it's the most
momentous announcement you can make in
your entire career you're like I want to
commute on an escalator yeah I'm not
gonna walk down I'm gonna go real slow
yeah I'm gonna stop at a footlocker
first and get some stuff wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]